字幕: Miyu Hayashi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
はじめまして こんにちは
私は 現在高校２年生の16歳です
ちょうど半年前 今年の5月に行われた
TEDxに行ってきました
それまで YouTubeでしか見たことのなかった
TEDという空間を初めてリアルで体感した時
私は最高にわくわくしました
その時のわくわくを胸に
今日はちょっぴり特別な自分に出会いたい —
そんな思いでここに来ました
私には 友達から言われると
すごく嬉しくなる言葉があります
それは 「ひーちゃんって
なんか毎日楽しそうやな」という言葉です
この言葉のように 今日は
私から皆さんにプレゼントとして
毎日が楽しくなる秘訣について
共有できたらなと思います
それを 「わくわくの輪郭」という
キーワードを通して伝えていきたいと思います
わくわくの輪郭について説明する前に
16歳の私から 皆さんに質問があります
今 皆さんは親族以外に
何人高校生の知り合いがいますか？
また 皆さんは高校生時代に
何人大人の知り合いがいましたか？
私は今まで 本当にたくさんの
大人の人に出会ってきました
その中で大人の人から
名刺をいただくようになりました
もちろん 名刺のような形に残らない
出会いもたくさんありました
しかし 高校生である私を子供扱いせず
尊重してくれた大人がたくさんいることに
とても嬉しく思いました
では 私がどのようにして
そのような大人の人と会ってきて
また なぜそんなにたくさんの
大人の人と出会ってきたのか？
それについて話したいと思います
高校一年生の秋 放課後
高校での 繰り返された学校生活に
少し退屈している自分がいました
月曜日は古文で始まり
金曜日は数学で終わる
学校が終われば 塾に行く
そんな生活です
また 退屈するだけでなく
「もったいないな 何かしたいな」
とも思い始めていました
そんなモヤモヤを
友達に話してみたところ
その友達も同じようなモヤモヤを
抱えていることに気が付きました
そこで私たちは ３人で なんとなく
学生団体というものを
作ってみることにしました
すると それを知った母校の中学校の先生が
「今度面白い人と会うから
よかったらおいでよ」と言うので
「面白い人ってどんな人なんかな？」と
わくわくした気持ちを胸に
行ってみることにしました
そこで出会ったのは
ある会社の社長さんの清水さんです
清水さんは
「今度大学生向けのイベントをするから
よかったらおいでよ」と
当時まだ15歳だった私たちを
まるで自立した大学生のように
尊重してくれる そんな大人でした
「大学生の中に 私も混じってみたい」
「なんか楽しそう わくわくするな」
という興味半分の気持ちで
なんなら興味だけの気持ちで
そのイベントに足を運びました
そこで私は 人生を変える
出会いを経験したのです
それは イベントに
たまたまゲストとして来ていた
これまた別のベンチャー企業の
社長さんである中馬さんという方です
中馬さんは 自分の人生について
自分の大切にしていることについて
本当に熱い目をして語っていました
「わがままであれ」
ありのままの自分でいることの大切さを
私に教えてくれました
この考え方と 中馬さんの力強い言葉は
今でもどうしても忘れることができません
今振り返ってみると
これらの かっこいいと心から思える
大人との出会いで
私のわくわくの輪郭は
とても広がったような気がします
なぜなら これらのかっこいいと
心から思える大人は
自分だけにしか見えない世界を自分で理解し
それを相手に伝えることができる —
そんなところに惹かれたからです
私はたまにふと 思うんです
もし 中学校の先生に誘われた時に
その場所へ行っていなかったら
どうなっていたんだろう？
おそらく 清水さんにも会えなかったし
イベントを知ることもできなかったし
中馬さんにも出会うことができませんでした
この出会いとは 「おもしろそうだな」と
わくわくする自分の気持ちに素直になって
イベントに行ってみたり
社長さんに話しかけてみたりと
全て自分の行動が招いたもの —
そういうことに気が付きました
今 私の話を中心にしましたが
今度は もっともっと皆さんに
自分自身のことについて考えながら
聞いて欲しいなと思います
今日から一緒にわくわくルーティーン！
「わくわくルーティーン」とは
わくわくを生み出すサイクルのことです
これこそが 私が初めにお話しした
毎日を楽しくする秘訣であります
このサイクルに気付き
わくわくの輪郭と名付けるまでの間
私は自然とこのサイクルを
繰り返していました
でも 自然と繰り返していることでも
きっかけ つまりルーティーンの一番初めは
いつも同じであることに気が付きました
それは 「なんとなーく行動してみる」
ということです
「行動」と一言に言っても
ここには少しだけ仕掛けがあります
それは 「いつもと違うことをする」
ということです
私が感じた 学校生活でのモヤモヤは
いつもと違うことをすることで
スッキリ解決されます
昨日と同じ今日
１年前と同じ今日
「あれ なんかつまんないなぁ」って
ふと 思うことはありませんか？
これって 毎日同じ道で家に帰ることと
似ているなぁって 私は思うんです
だったら たまには違う道を通って
帰ろうよっていうのが私の考えです
ルーティーンの中で 次にお話ししたいのは
「人と会う」ということです
皆さん 最近「はじめまして」と
言った覚えはありますか？
友達の友達に会ってみる
友達に誘われたイベントへ ついて行ってみる
「はじめまして」というチャンスは
意外と日常の中にたくさん転がっています
このチャンスを放っておかないで
たまには拾ってあげてみてください
ちょっとでもいいから
いつもと違うところへ
一歩踏み出してみて欲しいんです
「自分にはそんな行動力ないし
ちょっと難しいかもしれへんわ」
て言う人がいたら とっておきの
練習場所があるのでお教えしちゃいます
それは 今日のこのTEDxという空間です。
「はじめまして」をきっかけに
たくさんの人と関わってみてください
人と会う
そして その人のやっていることを知る
ハマっていることを知る
視点を知る
その人にしか見えていない世界を知る
そこで「なんか面白そう」
って思える話だったり
心の琴線に触れてくるものだったり
「なにこれ？」って
気になるものがあるかもしれません
「面白そう」つまりわくわくする瞬間が
あるかもしれません
でもこれって
百発百中じゃなくていいんです
先ほどとは逆に 人と会って話して
あんまりわくわくしないまま
終わってしまうこともあるかもしれません
でも 「あんまり面白くないなあ」
「あんまりわくわくしないなあ」って
自分自身でわかることも
とっても大切だと思います
なぜなら 出会わないと
自分がわくわくできるか わくわくできないか
それさえも分からないからです
なんだかそれってすごく
もったいないなあと思いませんか？
こういった 自分がわくわくするものや
わくわくすることをたくさん集めてきて
自分だけが知っている
自分がわくわくできるラインのことを
「わくわくの輪郭」と呼びます
でも この輪郭は
ただの境界線ではありません
「内」と「外」という概念は無いのです
なぜなら 「わくわくの輪郭」の
外側にあたる部分 この部分にも
自分のわくわくできるかもしれない対象は
たくさん広がっているからです
でも それがまだわからないからこそ
なんとなく行動して人と会う —
その一歩を踏み出すことが大切なんです
では このルーティーンの先にあるものって
何なんでしょうか？
どんないいことがあるんでしょうか？
そこには２つあります
１つ目は 「自分らしさが見えてくる」
ということです
なんで自分らしさが見えるかっていうと
同じ毎日を繰り返しているだけじゃ分からない
分からないだけじゃなくて
分からないことにも気が付けない
そんなことが 他の人と会うことで
見えてくるからです
「これは好きだけど
これ あんまり好きじゃないなあ」とか
「こっちよりもこっちの方が好き」とかいう
そういう自分だけの感覚っていうのが
どんどん見えてくると思います
例えば 私の場合だと
お話を聞く講演会よりも
参加者と一緒に何かする —
そういう ワークショップ型の
方が好きだったり
ずっと同じ作業を繰り返すよりも
いろんなことをちょっとずつ
やるのが好きだったり
成功談を話してくれる大人の人よりも
失敗談を話してくれる大人の人の方が
面白いなあと思ったり
人と会うことで自分が見えてくる
人と会うことで どんどん
自分が自分らしくなっていく
そんな感覚を日々感じています
人と会うことで
今まで見えていなかった
自分の側面を知れる
それって すごく素敵なことだと
思いませんか？
２つ目は 人とのつながりが
できるということです
人っていうのは本当に面白くて
人との出会いは また次の人との
出会いにつながっている
つまり 終わりがないと思うんです
自分の「わくわくの輪郭」を広げていく中で
わくわくルーティーンを
何回も繰り返している中で
本当にたくさんの人に
出会っていくことになります
「もっと深めたい 知りたい！」と思った時に
話をしてくれる人ができます
私の場合
最近 グラフィックレコーディングという
描くことで理解を深めたり
その場を促進したりする手法にハマっています
私はグラレコのプロである
大人の人と出会ったのがきっかけで
このグラレコが
私のわくわくできるものになりました
そしてその人とは今でも
私の練習ノートを送ると
感想を言ってくださったり
一緒にイベントを開催したり
「こんなイベントあるよ」って
教えてくださったりしています
それからそれから 今度は
私がグラレコにハマっていることを
知ったまた別の人が
「今度のイベントでグラレコやってよ」と
いう風に誘ってくださったりしています
実は私が今まで出してきたこのスライドも
グラレコ風にアレンジしてみました
こんな風に 人とのつなりがまた次の人との
つながりにつながっていくんだと思います
つまり このわくわくルーティーンには
終わりがありません
「わくわくの輪郭」というのは ずっとずっと
自分の中で更新されていくのだと思います
もっともっといろんな人に出会って
その人にしか見えない世界を知って
自分の「わくわくの輪郭」を
広げていきたいです
今はグラレコに
最高にわくわくしているのですが
もしかしたら もっともっとわくわく
できるものに出会えるかもしれない
そう思うと それこそ
めちゃくちゃ わくわくします
ここまで話してきて「わくわくの輪郭」
というものがどんなものかわかりましたか？
たくさん人と会って
たくさん自分でわくわくする
そうしたら自然と自分の「わくわくの輪郭」
というのは広がっていくのだと思います
だから「わくわくの輪郭」が
広がっていくことは
大袈裟ではなく これからの人生を
変えるきっかけになるかもしれないんです
今日のこのTEDxという空間だって
「わくわくの輪郭」を広げる
絶好のチャンスです
ぜひ 勇気を出して今日の何処かで
アフターパーティーでもいいので
自分から話しかけてみてください
その際に キラキラの笑顔と
「はじめまして」の力を
ちょこっと借りることもお忘れなく
そして 是非簡単な自己紹介で終わらず
相手にしか見えていない世界を知ってください
さあ 一緒にわくわくしよう！
ありがとうございました
（拍手）